your kids don't need to know who you
were before you had them you need to
know who you wish you were and they need
to try to live up to that person
[Music]
haley have you seen my blue
hey miss dunphy
oh hey dylan
you know i can see you right
no i did not know that
haley's just in the bathroom she'll be
back in just a minute thank you
claire i know you've got your methods
but so do i and i'm sorry but i'm not a
micromanager trust me i can provide luke
with the tools and guidance he needs
without uh smothering him
you think i smother our child it's not
your fault honey mother is part of the
word you never hear of anyone beings
fathered to death okay that's it i don't
want to hear anything about your new
method of doing things there is one
thing that works with these kids and
that is staying on top of them which
thanks to you my friend i will now be
able to do all night long
if i say something that everybody else
is thinking does that make me a mean
person or
does it make me a brave person
one who is courageous enough to stand up
and and say something
behind someone's back to
10 year old
you know hmm you look prettier now than
the day we got married oh honey and you
are even more handsome huh i didn't wish
i was in the bathroom
you're funny you're nice i have always
been nice
i've always been funny well
mom
dad ignore her
that could be anyone
phil and claire dunphy
yes hayley honey what is it i'm gonna go
get some shaved ice at the hotel next
door with some kids what kids just some
kids i met at the pool
okay um i should go with her where no
you have to learn to let go
turning a family vacation into a
honeymoon takes commitment
you can do it
aya the tiger
hello
i should at least meet them no that is
not
i
of the tiger
all right haley honey go and have fun
but don't get in anybody's car and be
back in time for your grandfather's
birthday dinner okay thank you okay
all right
oh god
that feels weird and good all at once i
know i was leaning up against that
nozzle a minute ago
bring it this way this way there it is
perfect thank you perfect
can you ask us to fix that light i asked
him but he just growled at me oh gosh
okay guys stop scaring bethany and fix
the light please don't make me come over
there
i'm busy you fix it
is this because i said i wouldn't come
to the dance with you
guess i'm a married woman people would
talk one dance with me you forget all
about it yeah i already have a husband
who doesn't fix lights please
thank you so much
claire i didn't come here to steal your
thunder your thunder is your thunder and
my thumb that is my thunder i know it's
just that god gave you so much thunder
yeah maybe too much
i hate how those women look at me you
think i don't know what they're thinking
ah here comes the hot one with the big
boobies that is gonna steal my husband
and maybe they don't let their kids play
with money
volunteer because i want them to see
that there's so much more to me
why didn't you tell me that maybe for
the same reason you didn't tell me you
had a weird thing for gauze
it's embarrassing
okay
i am sorry i made this whole thing into
some ridiculous competition and
i'm pathetic you're not pathetic
okay that's a little bit sad
okay ready
one
two
three
nothing's happening oh my god yeah our
kids walked in on us we were
as they say having sex that's not a
euphemism phil that's exactly what we
were doing having sex
in front of our children well they
weren't there when we started no
in fact you weren't even there when we
started
i don't do yoga it's a cover okay look
i know that from the outside
it seems like i have everything together
no not really
my point is that my life can be very
stressful and i have found a way to cope
with that stress and it's my little
secret
and i'm not proud of him hey claire see
inside hey is that what you do
no no
okay you're coming with me come in
but listen to me gloria
it has to stay between us
this is my sacred space
it's just
such a great release
thank you for not judging me why would i
if anything it makes me like you more so
how often do you come here not that
often no
okay
maybe a little often that's so sad i
live with four teenagers you live with
two adults no no it's so sad that you
come here so often and that's the best
that you can shoot oh
and that's with prettiness but in proper
stance practice okay thank you um have
to excuse me a little nervous i've never
been on the radio before don't worry
about it just think of it as a
conversation okay okay headphones volume
control don't get too far from the mic
okay make sure your cell phone's off oh
cell phone right and you're not chewing
gum are you no i'm not i just had some
temporary dental work done the last
thing i had last week
and welcome back to a matter of record
i'm cecil van gandy
joining us now in studio is district 43
town council candidate claire dunphy
thank you cecil
it's a pleasure to be here so
you're a first-time candidate tell us
what got you involved it all started
with a um a stop sign
i was concerned about
safely in our neighborhood and i was not
getting any satisfaction from city hall
what's wrong with mom oh this isn't good
she sounds drunk that's not our drunk
voice uh tell us about some of the other
issues facing our town where do you
stand on the city's
sewage and sustainability initiative the
so-called ssi one cannot really talk
about s
sewage and sustainability without first
discussing
recycling
once i hit the coast highway i didn't
stop
i turned off my cell phone
i ate fish tacos for lunch it was insane
i haven't felt that free in years
all my stress completely disappeared
and so did my keys
every new generation thinks they have
cracked the code on child rearing what's
the latest theory never say no
i say no every day in this house but at
night she's a yes machine
sure i had a little peppermint schnapps
at my prom but i hid it for my parents
and i kicked my boyfriend out before
they woke up it's called respect
i'm pregnant
you're gonna get fat
oh okay it's great it's great you're
pregnant that's great congratulations
wow it was a surprise yeah i'll bet what
did my dad say i haven't told him yet i
worry that he's going to think it's not
such great news oh
no don't be silly
he's gonna be thrilled
i knew he wasn't gonna be thrilled and
if history was any indication
he wasn't gonna be able to hide it
it's a french-canadian delicacy called
poutine well it looks like vomit so i'm
not pouting it in my mouth
we're here
hi
what'd you do to your hair how did i try
something different what looking old
i had to get to dad before he said
something insensitive to gloria
she's gonna get really fat though
she looks great doesn't she yeah
not really gaining weight the way i
would have expected i finally understand
why people say pregnant women glow
phil i've had three children
my dad has three tattoos like why you're
a dad ew it's so sad when parents tried
my mom double pierced one of her ears
and i'm like hello you're 50. so old
like ancient to have an ear piercing hey
you two decide to go to the dance well
yeah but not really but yeah what we're
going ironically to make fun of all the
kids who make a big deal out of it
ironic my ass alex likes drew she's just
playing it safe now there are the pushy
obnoxious moms who try and get involved
nudge them towards one another
we mean well
i have a head for business and a bod for
sin
yes you do ew this is a common area
i've been taking magic lessons as a
valentine's surprise
wait a minute the supposed hinge
salesman at your office the great
magesto of course i didn't recognize him
without his floor-length robe covered in
question marks and we also really do
have a reservation at that really nice
place down the street so we should
probably
get your check
excuse me can we get the check
but
are you really dressed
so wonderful
come on honey we should get going wait
uh do you have the key
no
but you do
i don't deserve you
[Music]
you